mesdames messieurs les chefs d'état et
chefs de gouvernement
monsieur le président chers donald tusk
mes chers collègues voudrais tout
d'abord vous dire combien je suis
heureux d'être à vos côtés aujourd'hui
25 ans après avoir été député européen
et président de la commission de
l'agriculture c'était au siècle dernier
c'était en 1994 monsieur le premier
ministre cheikh andré voudrais tout
d'abord vous dire que c'est un honneur
d'être ici dans ce beau pays qui est
depuis son adhésion à l'union européenne
apporte beaucoup à notre communauté de
destin est dans la continuité de
l'histoire du ppe et du rôle majeur
qu'ont toujours su avoir ses ses leaders
pour la construction européenne
je veux dire à mon ami joseph daul
combien en tant que français nous avons
été fiers d'avoir un homme comme lui à
la tête de notre parti
un homme de qualité leader respecté
négociateurs habile agriculteurs est
attaché à son pays et à ses racines
chaire joseph merci je sais combien ton
engagement profond pour l'europe restera
ô combien précieux l'union européenne
mais chers collègues est à la croisée
des chemins à l'extérieur de l'europe
nous avons à faire face à l'agressivité
commerciale de la chine et des états
unis au sein de nos pays les partis
populistes et nationalistes progresse
comment l'encore vu récemment et prône
un repli sur soi permanent
nous avons cette lourde responsabilité
d'être les moteurs d'une europe qui soit
à la fois stratège et qui s'affirme
durablement tant les défis qui se
présentent devant nous sont importantes
tout d'abord et avant tout le bric site
et je veux saluer la détermination
constante et l'habileté de notre ami
michel barnier qui a géré ce dossier
depuis trois ans tout en respectant
malgré les difficultés les choix de
royaume uni il a su maintenir l'unité
des 27 états membres
privilégier l'intérêt des citoyens et
proposer des solutions pour une paix
durable et défendre nos intérêts
économiques
par ailleurs notre nouvelle présidente
de la commission ursula von der leyen
l'a parfaitement démontré
l'union européenne doit définir ses
priorités
et dans ce domaine notre responsabilité
est immense c'est celle d'offrir aux
futures générations
un monde meilleur la protection de
l'environnement et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique sont des
priorités mais nous devons les aborder
sans aucune idéologie punitive
nous devons défendre l'instauration
d'une protection écologique pour taxer
les produits provenant de pays
extérieurs qui ne respecte pas les mêmes
normes que nous c'est cela protéger à la
fois l'environnement mais aussi défendre
les entreprises européennes et les
agriculteurs européens
nous devons défendre nos intérêts
économiques
l'union ne peut pas continuer à être
prise en tenaille entre la chine et les
états unis
nous devons mettre un terme à une
certaine forme disons le de naïveté en
exigeant le principe de réciprocité
temps pour notre politique commerciale
que pour l'accès aux marchés publics en
renforçant la compétitivité des
entreprises européennes mais aussi la
recherche particulièrement en matière de
santé d'intelligence artificielle ou
encore dans le domaine du numérique
pour cela il est primordial que nos
priorités stratégiques se traduisent
dans le budget européen l'agriculture
mes chers collègues et la pêche ainsi
que la politique régionale ne doivent en
aucun cas être les variables
justement du prochain budget de l'union
européenne enfin sur l'immigration et la
sécurité
c'est le pp qui a été moteur sur tous
ces sujets en obtenant des avancées
concrètes dans la protection de nos
frontières il faut aller plus loin plus
vite aujourd'hui avec le renforcement de
frontex avec la mise en place d'une
véritable coopération européenne et pour
harmoniser nos différentes politiques
nationales le défi migratoire est encore
et toujours devant nous et cela va de
pair avec la promotion du mode de vie
européen
ces règles et ces valeurs qui nous
définissent tous et qui doivent être
respectées par tous ceux que nous
accueillons chers amis aux côtés de
notre président donald tusk avec mom
fred des verts au parlement européen
avec ursula von der leyen à la
commission européenne et l'ensemble de
nos partenaires et avec notre candidat à
la vice présidence du pp
franck proust je veux vous dire que les
républicains sont d'un engagement total
au sein de notre famille politique
européenne
le pp 1 merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]